just like practice I think regardless we
should start over totally keep going
okay we're live somewhere somewhere
someone is watching hopefully cool I
don't see it but good morning everyone
how was everyone's long weekend we had a
nice day off yesterday because we had
recorded an episode with Lea Michele on
Friday which was delicious such good
stuff I can't believe that was Friday we
haven't seen you guys since and
obviously were changed woman
women snitches a changed one oh my god
because we got to sit down with Lea
Michele it was really like a spectacular
spectacle yeah so much how did you feel
like I know that the celebrity smile was
creeping out from your teeth I was
trying so like so hard to keep it cool
she just like she blew my expectations
out of the water because I really
thought she was just gonna be like super
just like she's like just straight to
the point I mean like i shouldnt think
she'd have as big of a personality as
she did ya know she was very um like out
there like you she'd a lot to say yeah
and like I didn't think she'd like be
like so like opinionated and cool and
normal yeah and it just like she blew my
mind like yeah she was they say don't
meet your heroes and they are wrong they
say don't meet your heroes but I've been
a few of mine and it's really been just
like a rewarding experience
yeah like a bang-up job you know yeah
hurts it's clear that um the beginning
of this episode wasn't made into the
stream we are in a new set up today
because of the squatter
yeah the squatters being evicted
basically the squatter was a euphemism
for a construction that was happening in
our backyard
coming up next to her which is exactly
Jays exciting because I can maybe the
only coffee and like maybe a croissant
min maybe they like want you know free
press on the toast and they like bring
like a fresh break pastry basket every
morning right but in the meantime it was
[ __ ] with the stream so we moved to a
different studio and so now here we are
and as we were saying like I think
changes is a great thing yeah I'm like
looking we look cute as hell I don't
really hate this and you know we're a
little further away than usual which is
always good for me yeah I don't really
hate this I love having a real
microphone to talk into so I know when
I'm on and when I'm off for podcasters
who are listening there's probably gonna
be a great audio episode for you I love
I love a mic like this anything that
we've decided that when we do go back to
our studio we're gonna take these mics
with us I think they're really like
there's something so like you know
Howard Stern about them something's so
joe rogan about them oh my god it's so
Rogen yeah
all
so we did an episode yesterday for our
patreon about mortifying
no and I think it's gonna go down it's
like one of our best patreon episodes
like I actually had a text message about
it from someone that we spoke about on
the episode Caroline about which isn't
that crazy but she said it was and she's
a like a toaster through and through and
she said was the best episode she's ever
listened to maybe she was there like
it's must be interesting to go to high
school with something that with someone
and then 10 years later found out find
out what they thought about it no that's
such a good call and I always like to
think I was littering her with my high
school friends last night like do you
guys have the same sort of memories is
like I do and I was like thinking high
school was like so at like the forefront
of my my brain because we had just done
the episode and I was like I wonder if
everyone like looks back on high school
like with regret yeah well what Caroline
was saying was like yes we all feel this
way like something what we were saying
is like I look back on my high school
South and like I want to choke her and
murder her and just tell her to shut the
[ __ ] up she was like everyone feels that
like way of just living your old self
that's good yes so I just also wonder
like what did everyone think about me in
high school you know you know I don't
want to know though you know I'm good
check that out at www.hsn also everyone
was so busy heating themselves that they
didn't like they weren't looking at you
yes the point right now too
self-involved yes also while you're over
there checking out the patron head over
to the new Instagram account at toast
news network it is our new busy count
feel free to follow like you know all
things tienen new shows we have two new
shows coming out in the next few months
which are very exciting so all your
breaking news will be there auntie yeah
Paula tienen like first-time updates on
host news network right also we couldn't
get the handle at tienen which is really
upsetting yeah okay and you know what's
so upsetting when you can't get a handle
because someone is someone has it but
that person is inactive like that it's
very mysterious be putting out contact
you mean you mean like the real Jackie O
yeah who has he just got married it's
some girl named Jackie O and like I'll
never be a regular girl she's just a
regular girl not an influencer I will
never be her and that's my [ __ ] cross
to bear I wonder how long she's been on
Instagram because I've been checking
forever so it's it's been tough times
but anyways so much happened this
weekend we have so many great stories
like I can say that was confidence today
like the stories are it and then we're
gonna like go off book a little bit
because Jesus's King came out literally
10 minutes after we wrapped our show on
Friday yeah we didn't know if it was
gonna come out and then all this
it's like he waited for the toast to be
over so like so that we could enjoy it
with everyone else yeah we were sitting
at lunch before Leah Michelle me
literally all had our air pods in
listening we were such Millennials like
that was so obnoxious of us we were
except it was it's so good I wanted to
get everyone's thoughts on the album I
am loving it and I feel like the
toasters are loving it everyone's loving
it but then you look on Twitter and it's
like varieties writing that this is his
worst album of all time and I'm like how
well the thing is when the life of Pablo
came out which I think was like one of
the best albums ever my favorite song on
it was ultra light because he had the
choir and it was like very gospel I
don't even think Kanye oh yeah he did
rap on it but there was like this
beautiful woman singing and it was very
very inspired by Jesus I think and very
Gospel II so to me it's like now we got
a whole a whole album of ultra light
beam which I'm just very excited about
and I'm not really like you know um
Catholic but I'm here for it Christian
swimming yeah I'm really here for it
yeah I like it's just it's so beautiful
such a beautiful message and also I'm
just like living for the Kanye press
yeah oh my god so the interviews we
talked about them a little bit I'm
halfway through the same interview but I
watched his interview with big boy and I
thought it was so so good and it really
is worth watching for yourself instead
of reading up in an article like we said
because just the way that he says things
even when he was talking about not
letting his some of the people in his
camp remember marital sex he was talking
about how he knows it sounds so crazy
and now the shade room's gonna be
writing it up oh that's right it's just
like it requires contact right I'd like
to read recaps of interviews because the
media is so slanderous I thought it was
so I thought it was so interesting and
there's so many good interesting
factoids and and knowledge it's really
like he talks like philosophy yeah I
feel like I'm in theology class that's
what most of air pool karaoke was I know
you didn't watch it but he did carpool
karaoke with James Corden but instead of
doing it in the car like everyone else
he took him on the plane that they
traveled to Sunday services I'm so
excited to watch it did they sit in the
cockpit like they were driving no they
sat on the plane they sat like heat
James cos found a middle seat okay
Connie's out of the aisle and there was
some guy in the window who was like
literally loving that he was sitting
there and then the rest of the choir was
around him and it was very interesting I
was thinking a lot about how if Kanye
definitely doesn't fly with them
regularly like it was definitely special
for them and James Corden was like being
really funny and I really appreciated
that Kanye like thought James Corden was
funny because I feel like Kanye could
think the whole thing was stupid and
just like me in a bad mood which I would
agree cuz like it is kind of stupid like
James Corden like trying to get his bag
about the overhead seat like stupid but
like I could see how Connie would think
that was incredibly [ __ ] stupid yeah
but he was like really into it and James
Corden was like so into it and James
Corden had obviously studied the songs
he was tell to because I hate when James
Corden doesn't know people's music I
think it's so disrespectful that's like
when Tim McGraw and Faith Hill came on
the Taylor Swift tour I didn't know any
other words so he obviously like did his
research and he was basically a part of
the choir and they just like broke out
into song like every five minutes and it
was really cool and interesting but
James Corden was just like really
sticking out like a sore thumb like they
kept showing the whole plane and it's
like James Corden is like just like his
skin is like he's just like you can only
see him in the middle of the plane and
just like really sticks out and he's so
[ __ ] British he's like oh my oh like
so British and he just really [ __ ]
sticks out wow I can't wait to watch it
I have so much good YouTube content to
watch because I've been saving I've been
um I didn't watch the Geoffrey start
yesterday video though because I want to
watch the two today I don't want to put
anything in your brain but it was like
one of the worst episodes it was it's
like they tried so hard to take this
episode and split it into two well well
then I'm glad I'm saving it yeah that
I'm gonna watch them together so I don't
have that feeling but anyways I think
it's time and we can always go in and
out but I do think that it is time even
though we don't have a clock so I don't
know if it's time
but snatchler is a time I think it's
time I think it's time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
yes I'm kinda hungry today I would love
a piece of toast I mean everyone should
always have a piece of toast except I'm
doing intermittent fasting so I'll see
you at 12 no we never talked about on
the show how actually delicious
toast is like it's just crunchy and
buttery I mean there's a reason why it's
called the morning toast psyche we have
the utmost respect for toast yeah and
alcohol yeah yeah anything that you want
to chime in with oh my god I know you
would be remiss if you didn't get this
off your chest and I'm waiting for you
but I'm so removed you are and you let
asado and you know what I would say I
would be service but I've never known
the feeling of what Remus is like this
is it this is the look this is the face
of Remus now you know what would happen
if she did not tell you that today's
episode is sponsored by noon yes it is
so getting in shape isn't about just
losing weight it's about learning
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself
that's more stamina to keep up with your
busy life finally getting into those
gold jeans being more in tune with your
body's needs or practicing more
self-care so if you are in the market
for you know a weight loss but like a
life bettering a habit changing solution
Noom just might be the place for you if
you're looking to break bad habits like
it's the stamina thing definitely really
speaks to me because I have no stamina
and it's like when you're trying to
build an empire you need to be able to
stay up past noon and that has been a
huge issue for me so newman's I have a
teaching solution that helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
food through personalized courses it's
based in psychology they teach you why
you do the things you do and in arms you
with the tools to break the bad habits
and replace them with better ones it's
not a diet it's a healthy and easy to
stick to way of life it's one of the
biggest and most accurate food database
is available and lets you track meals
visualize portion sizes NC calorie
density at a glance we are all chopped
for time so new masks you just to commit
10 minutes a day for yourself if you go
off track there's no shaming just tips
to help you get back on track tomorrow
chat with your goal specialist and Noom
community to get and give help to people
going through the same thing you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps make big progress sign up for your
trial today at noon calm / toast that's
n oom calm / toast what do you have to
lose visit new mom / toast to start your
trial today that's Noom calm / toast the
last weight-loss program you'll ever
need love it
sign on look amazing feel amazing be
amazing
ok first story you guys it's the story
of all stories Andy Joe
Arisa well it's been it's been a minute
Sunday night was the night I I can't
like we haven't had one of these
one-on-one situations in a why it was
like where the world stopped and pretty
much everyone watch it's like every
Housewives every pop culture fan like
was watching this and it was a great
moment to be a fan of Bravo and it was a
great even though like they're still
sort of in it and they're just figuring
out like where's Joe was gonna go like
it really is a full circle moment for
all of us who have been on this journey
and like from the beginning from before
they were even like convicted of crimes
they both went to jail and like now it
really is just so crazy how like time
for us like glue for us but not I'm sure
not for Joe in jail but it it's just
crazy that it's all almost over anyways
what did you think
overarching lis of the special I had
three major
the first is that Teresa is a star like
the fact that she time after time
continues to include the audience in
this update like back then she was doing
those interviews because she needed the
money but now I feel like she's less
desperate and she still continues to
like update the world on it and for that
I'm very grateful as a fan of her show
but I do still think that she needs the
money yeah but it's not so dire like I
actually read that their restitution is
paid so now it's just like for the kids
and but now it's just like her being a
stepmom yeah the second thing and
wanting to keep that house the second
thing I want to say is that Bravo's
satellite was spectacular spectacular as
an entrepreneur we're building a
business I know how hard it can be to
get a stream up and running and I'm so
grateful that they had a clear perfect
audio there was really no delay I
thought it was done spectacularly I
agree and I had said that if it was done
via satellite I was gonna be pissed and
I was not pissed I did like I would have
liked to see their body language
together in the room but I feel like I
got a sense of what's going on yeah the
third thing was I'm wildly impressed
with Joe's linguistic abilities I was
all day on Bravo before they were
playing like the olden trees when
Theresa got out of jail Joe and there
was a lot of Joe content and I really
realized how like English like was his
first language but he didn't graduate
high school and he was just he really
had a hard time like speaking proper
English was there wasn't his first
language well he was born in America but
I think it's howling this is first line
I mean it was boy he was born in Italy
but he moved to American he was only one
years old so I mean you would think
maybe English would be his first
language but given the lack of like
grammatical knowledge that he had maybe
Italian was his first language but he
said he took the GED courses and he took
a lot of computer courses and I could
really tell like after watching the last
thing on him four years ago and then now
watching this new special I was shook at
how well-spoken he was like yeah what
are you saying he was being mean to his
wife but how he was saying it was
grammatically correct yeah no it was
definitely like a new flavor of Joe
Giudice like still not like my favorite
flavor I'm not like gonna go for that
bag of chips but it was like a new a
little bit more respect a lot more
accountability and responsibility Joe
from Joe yeah Oh a totally totally
recognizing that like he has put
everyone in this situation oh oh sorry
yes when it comes to Teresa but when it
comes to his crimes he's still very much
like they did this to me oh yeah but
like recognized
that he puts resent his family in the
situation I think he he's in a better
place on that front yeah and I thought
it was really interesting to hear Teresa
there but they both seem so over it and
I totally understand understood what
Teresa was saying she's like honestly I
wasn't even angry at Joe like until I
got home and my mom died like I kind of
get like there Italians are very loyal
and she was even going to jail for him
like she was okay with it but then when
it really like impacted her her
relationship and missing out on that
time with her mom I feel like she
snapped then and she hasn't turned back
yeah but I also think it was just a
matter of time before she snapped
because like no no person could just be
put up with all of that and just take it
with a smile yeah you know so maybe if
her mom had passed five years later she
still would have been like oh I didn't
get those love and a half months you
know anything could have happened and
she would be like I didn't get those 11
and how about a month later ya know and
so that's when and why she snapped but
like I think she was bound to snap
of course I'm surprised she didn't snap
sooner report you to go to [ __ ]
prison no I know she's just like such a
champ anyways I thought it was
interesting I saw an article and he went
on his show his radio and E radio and he
said that he had one regret about the
interview and that was that he did not
defend the Caroline Manzo when like Joe
was saying all these things about her
and that she could be the wrap in a way
no and then and he was saying but like
Caroline's never been to jail like
Teresa was saying like maybe Caroline no
how does she know these things like as
if that she has some sort of like ties
to cry but Caroline's never been to jail
and any like kept his mouth shut
as I think he was supposed to but he
felt bad that he didn't have her back
that's that's nice to hear when Joe was
like there's the best thing that ever
happened to you and and he was like
actually my child is best thing that
ever happened to me and there was OC and
New York before New Jersey says it down
I know but like it was huge
no of course of course but like that's
just like such a dick thing to say was a
dick thing to say but I'm sure that like
I mean I don't think Teresa feels this
way because she gets all of the benefits
but Joe Giudice has only gotten the
negatives of being a TV star right
because he doesn't have called his wife
a Cu and whatever he called the dance
teacher the f-word like he is not made
for TV
whatsoever no and and then it sends him
to prison so like I understand his
frustration but overall I thought it was
interesting I feel like there's really
no hope for
unless he comes on I actually think it
would be better heard that I mean and
even Andy said it like Theresa doesn't
seem happy that he's out you know oh so
I didn't realize the situation where he
was in ice for five months oh my god
okay that's the other thing the special
was quite political actually because it
was really talking about you know the
flaws in our immigration system and when
Joe was saying that that thought the
five months he spent in that immigration
unit was worse than his entire time in
president it was really sad first of all
second of all he went to the Shu for
opening a window like interesting facts
like that is terrible a people in an in
a cell like that was shocking and then
like honestly Joe Teresa auntie talking
about Teresa contacting Trump as if
that's an actual option like Teresa's
not know that she's not a big enough
star to contact the president okay like
you wouldn't care no and he's no Kim
Kardashian is using for if you were in a
situation to pardon Joe Giudice or
Teresa like would you even well and this
is that's the point of pardoning Teresa
she's she it's not like she can't cam
boat I don't think she was that
politically involved before but what you
partying Joe and bring him back to the
states I don't know me thinks this is
like real first world problems like it's
not like he got okay he got it's very
sad cuz it Italy's not his home for sure
but his grandma lives there he's a place
to live and it's Italy like it's not
like some you know God for like it's
Italy like it said there's pizza and
there's like okay look I just don't
think it's that bad yeah it's just sad
for the kids for sure but it's like wait
not even let's used to go to Italy for
spring break
gia yeah and the kids are the kids are
busy well we lost our sweater but we
have a fly there is no way that the
viewers can see it but I see it yeah um
anyways this season of Jersey looks so
good so good Margaret Joseph's just
really you know coming out as the hero
that we all need it seems like the
divide from last season is even more
great than ever I know but like you know
my my heart is with is with Maas and
Margaret okay okay I kind of like
Jennifer I love Jennifer but I think
that's what makes an interesting season
it's not one clear villain that you know
like there needs to be a decent enough
like people on their side people on that
side and you need to feel conflicted
yeah and so that's what makes like
perfect house well that's actually a
great call that's what makes like it's a
perfect formula well yeah
are truly torn yeah so anyways I feel
torn in Dallas between because I like
Cameron but she's so wrong oh yeah no I
love Cameron I thought of calling her an
Instagram I just like its premium
content siping did you see her in that
blue dress this weekend like yes oh my
god he's always going to galas she's no
and she's a girl like because she is who
you think she is on the show like she's
truly part of society so we never say
yeah it's just it's good stuff okay are
you ready for our next story yeah it was
there anything else I wanted to say
about Teresa and Joe I thought Joe was
not looking straight at any moment it's
almost like he didn't have a monitor in
front of him like he was just listening
his ear because he was looking around
like I was like where the [ __ ] is this
guy looking yeah Oh what I wanted to say
was I really like appreciated and he's
um dedication to getting the logistics
of how this works um that I like the ice
with the ice and we're you handcuffed on
the plane and and how do they sit next
to you blah blah blah and then when Joe
was saying that he gave them restaurant
recommendations it's like yeah you you
took a whole flight with these you know
like your friends now yeah I thought
that was interesting too and it's just I
think they're not the one like they're
just carrying out the order it's like
right you know they didn't make they're
not the judge right why can't we all get
along no totally and I just thought it
was all at weird moments in time Bravo
is actually the pinnacle of like pop
culture and politics like immigration
and ice is like such a hot topic right
now and here's [ __ ] Joe Giudice like
telling it straight know it's crazy and
there's I see like there's all this
controversy about like what does an
actual ice detention center look like
and here's Joe Giudice Giudice like
first-hand experience telling us mm-hmm
who would have thought who'd a thunk
it's great not great but you know I mean
no but it's an interesting intersection
of culture yeah and politics okay next
story
another interesting intersection of
culture and politics because Selena
Gomez deletes Kim Kardashian's scheme's
promo and adds a Taylor Swift apology
photo it was really weird you guys this
is so weird and I just want to say
something before I forget because it
came on in my you birt'day her new song
love you to love me yes just want to say
for the record that I really liked it me
too Oh amazing look at her now terrible
and I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna end
it and I'm not gonna say anything
negative you know no but did we get the
fly we're on fire no this is like that
episode of Breaking Bad yeah that I
learned that I've never seen it I just
heard about there's a fly in the lab the
whole
so does about the fly it's a terrible
[ __ ] episode okay that's what this
one will be good let's talk about
Sweetman black movie so Selena Gomez
posted a snatchy ode photo of her in
skin she looked that's how like I should
look in scams but I don't you know ya
know same also she's just been looking
incredible like face body hair all of it
while she's on a press tour for I guess
her new music and um I guess she was a
recipient of this game's PR package felt
like she wanted to post a photo because
she genuinely enjoyed the product and
she was wearing the black leotard um
then I'm sure she promptly received a
call from Taylor Swift do you think she
knows that it because she just tagged
skin and shooting Ted Kim Kardashian do
you think she knows it's a Kim
Kardashian company maybe she just
thought it was a press box there's no
way she if she'd like I guess she didn't
tagged him right so maybe she just
thought it was like Spanx but like what
kind of rock can you live on I mean must
be nice honestly yeah it really comes
out of the house when you're like that
man considered this I just thought maybe
she thought like the feud wasn't at the
level that it is I think for sure she
didn't know um but it would be weird of
her
I'm just she get so many press boxes why
would she just choose this one to post
like I'm sure she in order for a brand
to get her to post something like it's
money well honestly I think what this
says is like that schemes are actually
incredible because I think she genuinely
just tried it on and I know the bodysuit
that she's wearing and it's incredible
and it's like butter and like maybe she
was just like sometimes you love
something so much you just posted to one
like because you appreciate it and
choose so that your fans like can get a
part be a part of it yeah so I think all
of this says to me that just skims are
incredible because they're even defying
like the biggest feud of our time but
then she deleted it and posted a selfie
of her Taylor Swift and her cat with
like a really lame ass caption I would
die for Taylor Swift she said my
ride-or-die I would die for this one
thank you for forever being by my side
you have taught me so much walk through
all of this with me stayed and you
remind me to be a better human I'm on
your side for life it's like okay we
understand no it's like the drama is
wholly unnecessary but I guess it was
like when she put that thing up she
really shook the world so in order to
like kind of settle the debate cuz if
you she just posted that I would've been
like oh selena has Swit switch sides no
or it's just like Selena is that maybe
or I would have thought the fight maybe
had dissipated if like Taylor's number
one
able to post about scams I just would
have thought like thinking about pulling
off but I think that I know the fight is
realer and more rare than this it's the
sort of thing that's just a window into
what's going on and it's bigger than
ever but I wonder if Taylor texted her
or like the Swift he's definitely one
insane in her dreams because the stress
yesterday we're going crazy so I can
only imagine her DMS was show rocket no
it was totally weird so was like I don't
know that Taylor was like delete your
story right now and give a love letter
to me right or she like was getting a
lot of heat and she is not the type of
person you know when she's getting heat
she like doesn't look at her divas look
at Twitter that should be like people
were commenting on her most recent photo
like the fifties are loud they can be
heard I know but I just feel like some
people are like beyond that how long was
it up for do we know a few hours yeah so
she probably caught heat yeah I don't
think it was necessarily necessarily
Taylor calling her and like berating her
but I think she just felt really guilty
I don't think Taylor ever even saw it
like well now she maybe in a few weeks
when Taylor walks onto tumblr like
she'll see someone posting about it but
no I think I think she's in tune I don't
know I think Taylor goes on tumblr
everyday and someone definitely posted
that on I think she really only goes on
tumblr when she's like planning stuff I
think she's aware of what happened I
don't but I think she's I don't think
she's mad at Salina because I think was
an innocent mistake even though it's
just not a mistake like but I think she
was just confused I think it was an
innocent mistake but like let's let's
play the game saying it wasn't like she
posted a Kim Kardashian company like she
was it's a cry for help right okay like
what does it all mean yeah it's a cry
for help truly no but she looks great in
it I don't want that to be lost here
like shook so good no and I just think
what the message here is like that skins
are incredible and they're defying
they're they're breaking all of these
walls down between these major stars
right I think skins like I don't know
how it's doing
have they had a restock or anything well
it's she's been releasing new products
like literally the cotton factory yeah I
really hope it's turning into her
billion-dollar company like Kylie
cosmetics is you know yeah oh my god I
need to talk about that vlog you sent me
Margo Margo sent me and I just have to
talk about it Margo sent me a vlog um
that Stassi baby who is Kylie's best
friend she's like the Jordan replacement
she was always like a number two now
she's number one no she was a number one
then she was number two now she's number
one again I was number two like hardcore
she was number one before Kylie met
Jordan like when they were in high
school they were just cheerleading but
where they were all homeschooled so they
went on that trip to Turks and Caicos a
little while ago I remember the girls
trip
yes if I forget you Haley skin with the
Kylie skin with the plane
and it was like such an amazing trip and
then Margo sent me that Stas actually
logged it so I was like oh man I need no
Stas was a blogger so honestly like when
you brought some of the Kylie Jenner
like pretty smart on it's like it's like
you never know when she blogs a lot with
her and like if you want to work your
way into our hearts like give us behind
the scenes of Kylie right and if you
want to get views just like get Kylie
Kylie such a good friend like always
popping in the frame and so she blogged
the whole thing and I have to say like
and I was so excited to see like the
house and like whatever it was the worst
vlog I've ever seen in my life she's not
have the vlogging talent I'm sorry
she literally kept being up her camera
being like hey guys we just some jet
skiing sorry I forgot to vlog like
Laurie she was just updating you and
then like pushes it and then I think she
had like some videos from like her phone
that she would like plugin it was so
poorly done she doesn't like have any
like kind of connection with the camera
like it was so disappointing she just
forgot to play she's like hey guys we're
going to dinner she had a blurry shot at
the table and then comes back up how do
we just say dinner like like but that
really now that I'm vlogging for our
patreon and like this is a project I'm
really enjoying and throwing myself into
it really is the vloggers cross to bear
of like I forgot to vlog some things I'm
going to tell you about it yeah but it's
like then you're just like hearing about
it she should start a podcast we've
started vlogs that like we're bad and
like we've not finished or we've started
vlog simin like we keep forgetting to
blog and like we're aware of it like if
you're a vlogger going to be self aware
vlogger yeah and I just don't think she
has that quality it may be she's getting
there and maybe she's new at this but I
just I have to go on the record saying
like she is a bad vlogger that is so so
funny I'm so invested in YouTube between
like the shane and i know real good
vloggers and it's like sorry I have an
acquired taste now yeah one like it
requires some talk about the
luxuriousness of the trip the trip by
the way you were like yeah you were like
yeah the vlog sucks but like you get to
see like the luxuriousness
really I didn't see anything I thought
her room
they do the tour ready they did a tour
and Stas is filming everyone like
walking into each person's room and
literally the entire block it's like
Tiffany when I go to Tiffany's room
stops in the camera I'm like it's just
her screaming the name it was so
annoying she was literally just
following people around to him in the
names jeff' like so annoying but it was
really interesting to see that Kylie and
Stassi shared a room yeah that is really
interesting also I want to talk about
Kylie Jenner's Friday night
her big night out and she got to
offender brothers she got into a fender
bender she went to the J Balvin concert
she was like ripping shots from the
bottle with Sophia Ritchie she was
trying on Williams glasses like she just
had herself a night and then she got
into a fender bender but she wasn't
driving or anything so like wasn't she's
okay but she did some crazy Instagram
stories with Sophia no I know they were
like really being like they were it was
literally watching
snitches story over her at a concert her
drunk with her friends like sleeping in
the backseat yeah and that's what also
the vlog was it's interesting that
Sophia is like really one of the best
friends and Sophia and Victoria and Stas
were on a boat one day and they were
obviously wasted and they were all doing
okay and everyone in the vlog had a July
everyone in the vodka jewel and I really
you think of them to be like in my mind
Sophia at a 65 years old like she's
lived a whole life but then you see the
city of her knees like she's just Margo
you know she's just Margo honestly like
snitch you have to become friends with
that I mean I would thrive you really
would that was what I was watching was
he your same weekend yeah um also can we
talk for a minute okay we're going into
are we going into weekend's because I do
want to hear about your guys's time at
bounce okay
I can't that was this weekend but now
that we're diving into the Kylie Jenner
friendships I would love to do a full
investigation maybe like a Shane Dawson
series on what the [ __ ] happened to Pia
Mia but CQC PME on Kylie's story this
weekend she reposted because PME had got
the Kylie skin lip mask and a face mask
and then Kylie we posted on her story so
like no bad blood I mean no bad blood
but you don't go from having dinner at
kris Jenner's house and letting them
sing free and you letting you sing for
joy remember that people never seen that
video Google Pia Mia
hold on we're going home Drake Kris
Jenner dinner dinner party they all had
dinner kris Jenner's house was a family
dinner they invited Drake and they
invited Kylie's friend Pia who was an
amazing singer and they let P mes sing
at the dinner sing a Drake song in front
of Jake and she sounded so good and
tricks watching and he's like blown away
and it's like how do you go from that to
like Instagram stories you know yeah I
don't know I would love it and then I
was like a PM es tan she had some pretty
good music mm-hmm and then Kylie like
was done with her so I was done with her
and watched a movie yesterday and she
was in it what movie after what kind of
movie it's a young adult never based off
of a book it was in theaters now it's on
Netflix good for her yeah she didn't
really speak but she was in it I don't
follow her on Instagram because she just
became someone interesting to me after
the Kylie yeah
those away but speaking of being like
partying like it's your 21 um how was
your weekend it was got a chaperon to
Halloween Day drinking with Margaret her
friends because I couldn't find anyone
my age to go out with and it was good
you know I felt like really stupid in
Toby like for a lot of the time like it
was me Ben and like literally Mario's
friends and it was like a little creepy
but bounce is such a good time I took a
bunch of shots had a bunch of chicken
burgers went home and fell asleep I was
saying to the snitch it really did look
fun like the music was great
they played toast at the club like I've
actually like it was that was shocking
but the music was great it was like it
bounced if you're looking for a day
drinking spot in New York like a rowdy
like that's really the only spot I would
recommend and it was lit like it was
just a random Saturday there wasn't it's
like a it's a sport sport club so it's
like based around the football games and
there weren't like a bunch of like huge
football games on but it's still really
poppin yeah um it's a great place to
meet meet guys all of Marcus friends
were mingling you know and the snitch
mean anyone I'm not a bounce cool and
that was how was the evening being
Ashley I go elsewhere no else Maria how
was the evening being Ashley oh this is
a costume that you party or like hearten
so hard and soda and wallet yeah yeah it
was great she like she was full of
ambition and Verve oh my god I love that
for her I can't believe it's been four
probably and then Miley Cyrus posted you
on our Instagram oh yeah so much
happened this weekend that's what I'm
saying yeah that was crazy like kochiya
for me as a first photo or tagged me
okay you got the third out of ten that's
pretty good
yeah but like my atha was the best one
out of all of them which group me in the
front but whatever I'm not complaining
good I'm complaining but ya know that
was just a great moment for me and like
literally all like she has a screen shot
at me and now you show up as like people
in her phone like you face if you ever
come up again like thing you have like a
whole collection of photos of you yeah
it's just something to think about
also what's crazy is it spin Halloween
for four days and Halloween is in two
days no and we're obviously gonna have a
Halloween special
we're gonna do it in here um yeah I
actually feel like this could be like
more of the vibe
okay we're gonna do a Halloween special
on Thursday is that what it is yeah very
exciting nobody's got star costume yet
or maybe they haven't I haven't seen
like we haven't seen your dress but I
have seen people but I haven't seen
anyone say I think it's gonna be really
fun my job and then I was thinking like
I didn't dress up for I didn't do
anything for Halloween it's like no I
I'm dressing up for Halloween on the day
of
like a bee in a big costume yeah someone
who went out on Saturday night like in a
full goth costume I can tell you how
incredibly stupid I felt and how it's
like we are too old officially like I'm
pretty much done okay and like a me and
Ben were invited to Heidi Klum's
Halloween party in the last few years
like I've really liked Rob Kardashian
and blac Chyna we did Danielle bergoglio
and dr. Phil and it's like I just don't
really have any me this year I
understand this I feel so stupid like
it's crazy because at one point in my
life like I loved Halloween like I would
do four costumes like it was just my
favorite holiday and I still loved it
and I loved watching it like for other
people but I just I just feel like
unless you like our taking shots and
blacking out like what are you gonna do
on Halloween I also haven't had enough
candy they like satiate the season and
I'm afraid that like it's gonna be over
soon so my building doesn't have like
children so there's no there's not even
a bowl in the lobby like some most
buildings have a bowl in lobbying like
you take a little piece or two before
four before you go up to your apartment
but my building doesn't have that so
I've really not been getting candy I'm
sorry my buildings kids don't thing to
do yeah it really is
okay next story because we're only on
story three Justin Bieber teases new
music a head of the holidays but calls
on 20 million fans for quote support
okay you guys and a lot of Jude look he
doesn't have that so he posted to his
Instagram a picture that says it was
text it says if this gets 20 million
likes Justin Bieber will release an
album before Christmas he said share it
like it posting her story I got to see
the demand wing love you guys pumped for
it I'm almost done but your support will
make me move fast he's gotten 10 million
likes as of today which is good I mean
20 million was very ambitious I don't
think he was ever gonna get that the egg
which was like the biggest deal in the
world reached 40 yeah I don't I just had
to like break the record is and then it
just kept going on in our holds the
record right um I think maybe he could
get the 20 million I just this is such a
weird thing to do I think it's really
this is with someone who doesn't have a
record label like or like a what's it
called when you get a music deal like a
record deal a record deal this is what
somebody doesn't get a record deal as
like 10 likes and I released my next
demo you know this is so loser II like
come on you have a whole [ __ ] media
team at wherever your label is like
working with you and you're gonna put
out some shitty little Instagram picture
yeah and it's just it's a weirdly
thirsty move from like one of the
biggest stars in the world but I do like
Justin Bieber's music like I don't love
Justin Bieber um but I do love Justin
Bieber and Haley you know what I mean
and did you like Justin Bieber's music I
thought that album purpose was spec to
other specs
albums like in the last 10 years like I
would say in the top 50 no I agree which
is what like just either give us some
new music or don't but this is like
weird this is so this is like inizio is
what it is oh yeah it's very you know
soundcloud rapper 10 likes and i'll not
release the next demo yeah agreed glad
we could all agree and move on swiftly
okay next story Jim Edmonds and Meghan
King Edmonds have announced their
divorce and now this all this drama with
a nanny yeah but Jim Edmonds is denying
an affair with the nanny and also
posting his Instagram like something
weird about how like they took in a girl
right so basically they announced they
were getting divorced and people thought
that he was having an affair with the
nanny because Meghan King Edmonds
responded to an Instagram comment that
suggested that so she kind of you know
lit the fires and then for sure everyone
was like she's a young beautiful like
nanny like who wouldn't want to [ __ ] her
and everyone was like oh 100% and then
Jim Edmonds finally chimed in and now I
firmly believe that he didn't [ __ ] that
Ani yeah because he's never chimed in
before also apparently she's not even
the nanny she's like I live in like
squatter yeah he said it's one thing
it's one thing to be accused of
something it's another thing that to be
so negligent and so careless and ruin
the lives of young innocent people he
captioned a photo of his sporting news
magazine cover
he said I did not sleep with our nanny
um and that she like wasn't that she was
just like she's not just a nanny she is
someone that we brought into our house
and promised to protect and look after
while she was in our home we have been
treating and raising this young girl
like she is our own child yeah so it's
like at first I was so sure that he did
and now I'm pretty sure he did it
because Jim Edmonds doesn't really speak
out he doesn't cry [ __ ] about the Bravo
fam and you're not gonna like put this
image in our head that she's your child
if you guys are sleeping together
yes so did they predict this who like a
Nicki said in five years you'll be
divorced
that's not a real prediction no but like
she literally said as Megan's face like
in five years you'll be divorced and
like your husband will be with someone
younger I don't know we're on this race
but did you see that Jordan Pruitt
oh yes and then Jordan Pruitt the
disease
are who we adore got involved Margo
explained what did she say she I think
commented on his Instagram and was like
how could you like with the nanny or
something and everyone was yeah I mean I
really made me wanna jump to the rhythm
and dance to the music after watching
the airport karaoke I just like need to
travel with the choir with me everywhere
I go they know how to harmonize well
cinch and I are pretty good we're back
up the answers and we are also piano
players and snappers do you know how
we're jack of all parties we are the
jack of all trades margot shares with me
i don't know how to harm since we got
this because do anything we set our
minds to no we work off of like songs so
jordan prove it okay you make me wanna
jump to the rhythm and you're just
singing quieter that's our version of
organizing okay that's what we bring to
the table so if you want to hit it you
make me wanna jump to the rhythm and
dance to the music and get this together
with show how we do i'm gonna prove it
is still out and about you know making
headlines yeah and just like speaking
truths you know is she though human I
actually believed she amendments here
Jim Edmonds has never been a petty man
do I think he was the most faithful no
did he [ __ ] the nanny no because she
wasn't than any squander no but he can
say like I didn't [ __ ] our nanny because
I she wasn't in any it's not a lie
that's a half-truth and I don't trust
you my men so that's like I'll wait till
I hear from Megan and she has yet to lie
down right but now do you think she'll
make a grand return to Real Housewives
of Orange County she did film one
episode for Shannon's birthday
I don't think um I don't think that she
will either I feel like she was never
really in it yeah I don't think that she
like loved it and she she like was there
for a reason in first season and that
was to bring down Brooks and let us know
that he doesn't have cancer I never
forget like the brave and courageous
work that she did it was very brave and
very courageous but I think she's over
it like she has her bez and she's gonna
do something else and I think she'll be
like dating someone else in a year yes
she got her kids and that's all that
matters and she like has her rockin bod
and like in her like Jean Jones outfit
with her Gucci fanny pack
she'll be fine so fun okay fade the
final story like just gonna end on a
happy note because this is the most
beautiful news in the world
Lauren Bushnell marries country singer
Chris Lane on Friday night in Nashville
like drop to People magazine cover what
one minute after the wedding
yeah and just so with glee like took our
breath away
Lauren Lane is born she looked beautiful
like I knew they were getting married
super fast because when Amanda Stanton
was on the show she accidentally said
that she'd got the invitation that was
like two months ago so you're supposed
to release it like six to eight weeks
before the wedding
and so I was just like basically waiting
for it to drop and I didn't realized
that Amanda said and had not Instagram
story that day at all which is very
unlike her because once I saw the People
magazine thing I went to a man that
stands Instagram for like some content
and there was nothing so then I was like
oh something is something is legit but I
didn't see her I don't see usually after
that like people will post content I
still haven't seen one thing from it
from inside they took away everyone's
phone no um so the only stuff that we
got I guess a when they liked the
after-party was lit and they had their
phone so you saw like a man dad or
something just like went to a club in
Nashville I think there was an
after-party for the wedding then the
next night they went to Jason Aldean's
um but so you just tell like the twins
and Amanda and like I have I looking
amazing like she just she just shows up
shows out alpha female and it's like
this is the wedding of the year like and
she's a single girl hell yeah I'm gonna
show up and show out you never know who
you're gonna see maybe some of like
Chris's country friends right no it's
like now we can make another you know
bachelor country duo yeah and Chris are
so cute and they're just like so normal
and I kind of people like got married
like as someone who's engaged for 15
months it was far too long like just I
don't care
and I think that's really smart of them
yeah and when you know you know and she
was engaged she did a long engagement
thing right it's just and it didn't pan
out yep so I think I think this is so
beautiful pictures like am i dying
I'm sure that we will like in a curated
beautiful sort of way right like another
not exclusive or something yeah and
she'll just like post them to her
Instagram yeah but no one had their
phone so no one took pictures right
which is nice I only want to see premium
content not wait for it I'll wait
I don't need to see like the blurry ass
of her walking down the aisle like yeah
where yeah we know where it was in
Nashville like a country club
I'd like a secret garden a cute
beautiful she's great she's like an
elegant [ __ ] like yes she is a great
style great taste like I'm sure it was
beautiful wedding and she has like a
very specific vibe you know yes very
Nashville - yeah well those are the five
stories that you needed to know and now
you know them if there's a very blunt
right to the point
we are not gonna recap this Shane xjl
everything because there's another
episode today so we will recap it
tomorrow because Jack and see the first
episode and honestly I did and there was
really nothing to recap it was quite
boring so we will recap that tomorrow
and then tonight we have Real Housewives
of Orange County
yeah and also tomorrow we have four
houses have doubts but like a really
like quiet Bravo moment and new Atlanta
premieres November 3rd so like then
that'll come back into the fold
and Jersey premieres November 6 which
also means that like these two other
actually no we're like mid-season on
Dallas was they had four housewives in
rotation the next couple months is gonna
be heavy but do you guys want to recap
Dancing with the Stars oh yes
Kurama went home which is not shocking
because krama wasn't very good but he
wasn't the worst no or the most
controversial so you would really every
weekend I'm like okay shouts when I
serve I he shouldn't even been in the
bottom two he hasn't even been in the
bottom two because in the bottom two
with crown drama and Kate Flannery and
you know what thank you for bringing
that up for Kate Flannery because it
really sucks like she doesn't have like
a ton of fans like she was on the office
so she's pretty famous but she doesn't
have like Stan ally Brooke v Harmonizers
look except you said the Harmonized I
mean like she's a cult following and I
don't even think that many people really
know is she is but she is like trying so
hard she's so like she's older so it's a
lot harder for her like to compete with
[ __ ] Hannah brown and Lauren Alaina
who perform on stages like it's just an
Hannah Brown has like a dancing
background Lauren goes and performs like
it's just so different for her and she's
so good and she's one of the best
answers but I think she's also gonna go
home soon I think it's gonna go eat it
Sean Spicer Kate Flannery and then when
they split up okay so the format last
night was really weird because they they
did the dances and then they split up
everyone into two teams so I do a group
dance that didn't matter on because they
put all the good people on one team and
all the bad we have a team [ __ ] up you
know and it was trying to make us think
that that was like a coincident no but
now it's like there's so few dances to
fill the two hours they have to come up
with dumb [ __ ] that's fine give me your
group dances but like make it fair
oh yeah basically like core emotion
spice or k2 honoree and and Kel Mitchell
who by the way Kel Mitchell in Witney
Carson are like underdogs that are
fantastic in Kelly's show every week
come
Hills in the same spot as Kate Flannery
where they're both pretty good but
nobody really liked Kate Flannery isn't
good she's just trying really hard no
kids very good she wasn't good last
night but she's very good who was number
one it was a tie for four it's always
the same four people and they were all
on the same team
James Lauren Hannah and Alec yeah one
team last night Cal yeah they gave them
more advanced dance moves in on that
team and then the other team like it was
like easier I mean probably but like I
don't know it's just like what's the
point of us even watching if I call
ready cutting out happens right so and
what was so crazy is like last week's
Ayla burns they cook went home and they
told her she was going home and you
would have thought like they told her
that like you know her dog died like she
couldn't not stop crying like cry cry
cry cry cry I couldn't get a word out
people were hugging her like they
literally had to pick her up Kurama went
home he did like a little sachet and he
had a really good attitude about it he
gave everyone a hug he was like he was
literally like twirling around the dance
floor it was like really cute like
that's how you go out you know now
sailor breathing code is only gonna be
remembered for balling on the bone no I
feel celebrating they cut go but I feel
like he was ready you know like it's so
much work I'm sure he was like he wasn't
he knew he was it's bittersweet because
you like you want to win but at the end
of the day it's like you not to dance
anymore and you have to go through
[ __ ] hours of training a day and like
you get to go home no for sure and then
like you have to be relevant you got to
make some money yeah but I don't I see I
like in fact we hadn't gone to Dancing
with the Stars which we did and we were
on TV I wouldn't understand micellar
bring the cook was crying but I really
do understand like it was so much
pressure she like was just caring for
her like the weight of the world and the
weight of like her mom's legacy on her
shoulders and I think she also was
enjoying doing it and liked for it to
all come crashing down in an unexpected
way thanks very heightened like in the
emotions yeah it's like a vacuum there
is so heightened it's insane also
interesting news yesterday was that
Christie Brinkley was a ex-husband who I
believe is Taylor's dad yeah his last
name is coaster cook mr. cook got
engaged to a 21 year old college student
he's about 60 they got engaged over the
weekend so congrats yeah Congrats like
to the family really I also kind of need
to talk about Hannah brown oh so she was
like in a tough spot yesterday he's been
like stinking it up well she was on her
Instagram stories basically saying her
feet were super swollen and I went to a
wedding in like dance the night away in
some shoes and then took an airplane
which like does not make me think it's
like that crazy
but she swears like her feet were
indispensable she dancing sneakers which
like okay great whatever did she mention
her swollen feet on the show in here no
she did on her Instagram stories that's
the only reason that I know well she and
her partner called her insecure and like
people were really upset about it but
like I don't think he meant it that way
I think she wanted to kill him when he
said that yeah cuz like she was just
looking for some support cuz she got
some like comments from Carrie Ann Inaba
and then like when Alan Burstyn is going
and like hopping on the same train like
that's your partner had my back on TV
I agree but also like she is she has had
the ideal experience up until now like
everyone wants her to win she has a ton
of dance experience like it wasn't that
hard for her to get started and she's
never experienced any sort of um
challenge in the show yet so this was a
challenge like gotta roll with it
grumbling no totally I just like she
needs to but she needs to bring it back
yeah she's struggling right now I really
like I find Bruno to be so annoying oh
my god can he sit down can you get your
hips like it's so much so [ __ ]
annoying does it like he's so extra on
purpose like an episode he's like always
no that's what he does he'll never sit
he'll never sit just like sit the [ __ ]
down and he like just as so extra and I
find him so annoying and we got it I'm
not to see my favorites one meet you and
you know he gets a lot of boos but he's
very constructive very constructive and
like he's nice when he like at the
appropriate times yeah and like he has
sometimes he does things wrong but like
honestly
cariann I can't stand ain't you saying
the horny stuff last night oh my god I
just I couldn't
she's the jet like I don't love the
whole judging system on Dancing with the
Stars like I said I'm new here so I
don't like the whole like I don't like
the panel of judges really and I don't
like that they get judged because I
think the judging methodology is super
unfair no I'm with you I mean the judge
I skip through the judges like I don't
want it I don't care what you have to
say just let me see the scores
yeah yeah I skip through the judges too
it's the best part yeah the show's so
much shorter this show is so I mean now
that there's no few dances like you can
really finish the show in 45 minutes
which I like because a two-hour show is
a lot beats I really want to start
watching 90 day fiancé like legit
because I went to dinner with my friends
and my friend Margo and Rachel they're
obsessed the 90-day fiance and they were
like tell me this story about this a
couple in Nigeria I'm like it sound so
funny but it's two hours and like I just
can't take that on yeah and it doesn't
need to be no that's tough I'm sure it's
great but like it's nice when
you're not involved because once you're
into something like then you have to
like pull yourself away from it yeah
like me watching the affair I've
officially stopped okay
I've officially stopped I didn't I
haven't started the new season yet it's
a type of show I like to binge so
because you like to just don't torture
yourself I like the show I like more
attorney like so much Wow okay I don't
want to like fight about it but it's
just you waste it like so many hours of
my life
did I tell you to watch it yes on Yom
Kippur you know I think you know you did
no no but thank you you had brought it
up and I said yes watch it but like I
didn't say the affair liked it because I
yeah I forget that I watched I think I
brought it up because I was watching
billions and it's like right next to
that on the Showtime app and you said
yes watch it and so I watched it
shocking that you don't like it honestly
I think it's a good show oh my god it's
like so much I need you to watch it just
so know that Novak I know okay anyways I
stopped so I'm gonna stop talking about
it because I don't want to encourage
anyone to watch it because it's so bad
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast if you have not gotten
tickets to the dirty jeans tour head
over to girls no job comm a bunch of the
shows are sold out some of them still
have tickets especially the ones that I
just added which are Tarrytown New York
Verona New York Tarrytown
ramaa Ontario Atlantic City New Jersey
Englewood New Jersey and Verona I think
I said that Turning Stone turn those
stones y'all know that's something I
always forget one Kansas City Missouri
that one's almost sold out
also um if you want to come to the
Beacon Theater I did release like 70
tickets that I was holding for myself so
feel free to go over to Ticketmaster and
hit that up mmm we will see you tomorrow
so we're listening to the morning show
so Monday morning show we go like Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so feel free to subscribe to
YouTube like this video get the comment
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast we found so that's iTunes
Spotify stitcher I already know public
videocast box feel free to subscribe
over there I leave a review about how
people sending in smart we are we love
you guys so much you are just like this
episode sending a really sad about it
head over in patreon.com Sasha morning
toast for so much more premium content
we have an episode with Zack and Olivia
we have our high school recap episode we
have high school prom pictures up on the
patreon only available all here wait
that's not enough content for you you
were on an episode of bubbly sesh oh my
god yes my homework podcast came out I
was on the Hallmark Channel official
podcast recapping the first countdown to
Christmas movie which is like such an
honor thank you for like including me
and like that really isn't really it's
not
to be nominated and thought of and the
episode is so much fun I had the best
time at the Hallmark offices and you
should check it out it's called bubbly
sash hips we'll see
you